hello everyone I am devendra Kapadia and
the soft no--nor
I and Adam stress bonds key to the non
senior developer we'll be talking about
what's new in calculus and algebra we
talk about new things in derivatives
limits optimization equation solving and
we also have something interesting to
talk to you about online course
development and college calculus so
thank you very much and I look forward
to seeing at the talks
so I will talk about what's new in
calculus and algebra is a joint joint
talk with Devin Drock Kapadia and so
here's the plan for the talk I will talk
about improvements for optimization and
solutions of equations inequalities and
the vendor will talk about enhanced
derivatives limits integral summation
transforms and then about benchmarking
documentation on my courses so let me
start with the first subject so here are
a few metals that have been added for
exact optimization so first is a pretty
general methods it's variable
replacement method for optimization of
trans central functions so basically we
like if we have composite like this we
can we can transform it into
optimization in terms of variable
replacing sign and one of the variables
X or Y or actually Y because it's here
so we have to we have different two
variables and this way we can we can
reduce this problem to solving
polynomial optimization problem which is
something we we actually have algorithms
for so for instance this one works best
by its transformation and we got a
result here is a min value also so we
can become transform from X Y variables
to two exponents of X Y and cosine 2x
minus y variables with the appropriate
transformation of the domain over which
we we optimize and we get the max value
so another case that we have added or
univariate trig functions with
commensurable function arguments so for
instance these are business function of
something at the function of three times
something trig functions so we can
reduce it into one function of one trig
function of this argument and optimize
in terms of this function over the dot
over the range of the inner function and
this way we we get the result of
optimization there is rather complicated
algebraic number and Max value of this
function here we we get transient on a
root object that but again we we can
recognize that this is the square this
is the same argument right this one is
twice this and plus one it's okay just
translation so so again we can reduce to
one together matching variable so now
it's a more complicated problem is so we
have several periodic functions with
incommensurable periods now so the
theorem is that if we if inverses of the
periods are linearly dependent over the
rationals then we can treat them sort of
as independent variables so the set of
values will be dense in the of f 1 FM
will be dancing the the range of of them
taken separately so for this to work G
and F have to for instance if there are
continuous it works that the more
general statement is that the range of
each function has to be closed
containing closure of the continued
values that continuity points so and
this is something we can check using the
function singularity data that we have
so here is here is something here
here is one function there is another
one with linearly independent inverse of
period and third here is the third one
and the mean value is this so we can and
this is the one that takes slightly
longer about 30 seconds on this computer
so here's the result that's quite
complicated quite quickly but it's
doable we got the exact solution
here is the same kind of problem over
the integers so here one and the
inverses of our periods have to be
linearly dependent over over the
rationals and and again we can compute
mean and Max value in such cases so max
value have signed this that's easy
here is I did sign over the integers so
it's just sign of integer values and and
the max value is 1 min value is minus 1
that's today they never quite reach the
plus and minus 1 but the infimum and
supremum are are the same as if it was
continuous function here is slightly
more complicated case so we have several
of these functions and we can also see
that so these are valued values at
integer points they're all above this
minimum or infimum line and here is a
max value or supremum of such a function
again we can see that values of integers
are we're going be to below the line but
not quite reaching the line other case
so univariate time elementary functions
over the integers of so basically these
are functions that do not do not have
periodic parts so in particular that
with a finite number of roots and over
the reals and we can we can use them to
solve it solve the optimization problems
over the integers so this is basically
by optimizing the univariate function
over the reals and then taking the
nearest integers to to all the local
optima and here is some very easy case
so maximize me my of min and Max so
basically we can we can do all the
arguments of min and Max separately and
it's much faster than treating the
maximum or minimum as a general
piecewise function which which what was
what we have been doing earlier version
so this took 25 seconds now it takes a
quarter a second
now for some improvements in equation
solving so one of them is we can compute
topological operations of solution
solution sets of real algebraic systems
equations of inequalities so for
instance here is the semi algebraic set
described by one inequality we can
compute cynically competition which
means we can solve the inequality got
explicit description and we can also get
the explicit description of the boundary
of this set so here is the picture so
here's the whole set here it's just the
boundary given by this inequality so we
can do the same for closure interior
exterior and we can do this for
connected components so here's to
indicate the composition of the set and
here the components separately so we we
get a list of the unique all the
compositions of each connected component
separately service component 1 2 & 3
a and secondly improvement is related to
what I've shown for the the for solving
of optimization problems with
[Music]
incommensurable periods so here is we
have assistance of die of Hunton
equations with coefficients that are not
rational numbers so earlier versions we
require the rational numbers in their
frontal equations here we can you can
have since we have now developed
technology to decide whether some set of
algebraic set of non algebraic numbers
is linearly independent over the
rationals now we can use this to reduce
a problem the fountain problem with non
rational coefficients to a system of
oblems with rational coefficients and
here's an example this single equation
reduces to composition of pal equation
with linear equation and here's
something we have complicated one
complicated equation reduces to a system
of equations that's actually quite easy
to solve Thank You Raymond Roger okay
I'll talk about some calculus
improvements and basically last year
Roger said that you know we should drive
back activity into calculus I mean
calculus has been a strong point for
ever but we just wanted to get back into
this kind of the act of improving the
major functions D and limit I won't
mention the other one which everyone
knows that's integrated but we wanted to
really start making improvements to the
existing functions and you began with
derivatives in version 11.1
various things beginning with let's say
sine X and so that's a formula for the
nth derivative depending upon the index
n over here and you can check that it
agrees with your intuition in the first
few cases since
derivatives have been studied by various
people but they were not in system so
one too difficult to put the table in
and then do some other work on top so as
soon as I did that Adam said oh yes you
know I can make derivatives go faster
with this method so he basically use the
nth derivative to make the actual
derivative computations for high orders
go fast so here's the billionth
derivative of sine X done instantly in
version 11 points but it took forever
earlier not that this particular example
might be important but shows that you do
something that you build on it and then
meanwhile only came along and talked
about the liveness rule and the chain
rule stuff with that so we had nice
formal a very soon for the product rule
that looks formidable but if you just
let n go to one it's just the product
rule from calculus and similarly we had
a chain rule the feed Bruno rule that
they spoke out right now it's got bail y
on it and
you put n equal to 1 you get back the
chain rule from college calculus so all
that looked very nice or algebraic but
my worry was there's nothing geometric
about these things you know it's no
think of a versus it being very boring
compared to Fourier series and that's
mean the impression but recently Michael
Trott point out to me that Michael Barry
actually has a very nice paper where he
says that the higher derivatives of
function produce oscillations what does
that mean so here's an example here's
the nth derivative of Gaussian and if
you plot the higher derivatives you can
see him going from 0 to 10 to 30 to 70
it goes quite fast because they've got
these hyper geometric so here then when
you do that you actually should see some
oscillations so in a sense Taylor sees
are very similar to Fourier series with
the higher term which in normally
neglect being like the higher Fourier
harmonics which get thrown away in any
approximation which is a very nice
viewpoint at any derivative then it only
came about because we didn't derivatives
over here ok meanwhile Roger realized
that there are these so-called holonomic
sequences so that's something you worked
on for version 7 so for example Bessel J
is holonomic in N and what that means is
that it satisfies a recurrence relation
in that variable so in earlier versions
if you found the high derivatives of
Bessel J they would just blob because we
didn't use the recurrence over there so
you'd go up and down up and down up and
down and get a huge mess which could
even blow all the memory on your machine
but now you get back this beautifully
compact answer for the tenth derivative
and maple doesn't so that's good always
okay so finally something that really
affects our users so for a long time
people have kind of observed complained
whatever that we could not differentiate
with respect to indices let me give you
an example so here's a function f of an
index variable you sum it you want to
find there is respect to X 5
and that looks easy but it's very hard
to actually carry it on practice
so now etn jose who know what tensors
got together and actually did a very
nice job of doing the derivative of
these things okay similarly you can do
inactive stuff which is very useful
because if you did their actual sum it
it'll blow up and you get back some nice
answers
so basically derivatives become much
much nicer in version 11.10 jan 11 point
2 we decided a little more serious about
particular set of functions and focused
on limits and so Adam rewrote the limit
function implement the so called grunts
algorithm that's a good example which
looks like it should give infinity and
it does in version 11 point 2 if try an
earlier versions it just hangs to my
knowledge we also have Max and min
limits pretty useful that's a very
simple example and we actually can go
quite hard on the examples over here and
get very complicated periodic function
like Adam showed look at the max and min
limits okay the real big breakthrough
was multivariate limits which we've been
trying forever but it finally worked out
so you're the college textbook example
you're a function of two variables you
plot it the limit depends upon the
direction which you approach the origin
from so you try it along some lines you
get different values and that says that
the limit does not exist
so multivariate limits are completely
new in version 11 point two we have
tested them against all the standard
vector calculus textbooks and this week
I was testing them against 1000 examples
more you think got to number 890 so far
forever right okay and finally discrete
limits another nice area sequence limits
which people have requested early on so
here's what we call a densely a periodic
sequence it oscillates widely
and of course the limit doesn't exist
the discrete limit which is new function
the sequence limit doesn't exist however
you can still compute the max limit in
the discrete case using items technology
for maxima and minima and you can also
compute the mini limit so basically what
we have is a very nice improvement for
limits all over the place and you ever
talk tomorrow where I'll actually
discuss the results of a large benchmark
with 1 million examples we range with
version 11 point 2 with maple 2017 and
sin PI and of course I'm speaking what
we've done very well so I'll show you
tomorrow that actually we have a nice
limit in version 11 point that talked us
tomorrow at 4:30
ok on the transform side we have nice
improvements for periodic transforms
which Roger observed are easy to do
because you can reduce your transform to
a finite interval and you have plaster
and some example which would actually
impossible early on there's a plot of
the Laplace transform for complex
arguments the Z transform is much faster
for multivariate inputs that's important
for future we also have the huncle
transform which we introduced kind of
pure mathematical because it had to be
done
maple has it but then you realize that
in fact it lets us do two dimensional
Fourier transforms quite nicely so here
is a two dimensional fourier transform
that works very nicely in version 11.1
the hunkler transform so now if we do it
over here you see that the fourier
transform back quite quickly for a 2d
function no possible before and that's
all coming from a huncle transform
evaluation ok so we did the hunka
transform and then the question was what
remains where I'd want to Don transform
for a long time that's the one that
determines the mathematics of CT scans
that people go
true and so the idea is very simple you
have let us say a section of your body
and you want to do a CT scan of it so
you send rays or whatever from these
directions and then you want to
reconstruct image image reconstruction
and that's what the radon transform does
and that's a hard problem to do directly
but even how to do in the inverse
direction but you know we had the huncle
transform huncle chaos 2d fourier and
then 2d fury has given us Redang so we
have kind of written on each wave to get
to the next level okay and you have a
nice plot so basically when you do a CT
scan the machine would get this picture
and then it reconstruct the original
image from that and finally go on to
where my heart really has been for the
last one year that's education so if you
only been kind of on the forefront of
Education but Roger said why don't we
try and actually do a complete calculus
textbook with people from language in
Mathematica so I had interns working
through the last summer this summer they
finished a month ago and now we have a
complete solution of this book by
Stewart around 1,500 examples Stewart's
book is quite popular he you made a fair
amount of money on a table house worth
28 million dollars with that sort with
that money
it's called integral house fittingly and
so now we actually have under our belt
the complete solution manual for James
towards book for our own education we
are not planned to share the anyone at
the moment so this is purely private but
it's got every single exercise solved
from this index you can just go in and
get to every notebook there are lots of
them and your sample notebooks in fact
when perico's working on this we had to
solve differential equation with three
solutions I was working on it I gave my
function and so we have asymptotic D
solve which we'll talk about tomorrow
morning in a talk with Adam on
asymptotic expansion so what we've done
is to use current functionality and
future functionally to come so does this
solve the whole book we done at all it
took a long time but I'm confident we
have done this
so that I think there is really nice
achievement thanks to all our wonderful
interns and Henry and people that and
who really work hard we don't lots of
work on documentation side
etai has worked hard to make the d pages
better the limit page better coming up
after that so d is now a much nicer page
most cope more applications more college
calculus applications and coming up
integrate in version 11 point so we had
dean 11.1 limiting 11.2 integrate eleven
point three some in the version after
that some conversions division after
that and meanwhile we also added
probably two thousand examples of the
pace for special functions we've done
hundred of them will go a hundred fifty
more in a few months and so you should
have pretty much a complete refresh of
all calculus documentation the one year
the last one the next one year or so and
one last point that if you did all this
my question what do with it so well I
don't intern this summer John Clark from
Caltech he joined me and I mean he
worked together produce a full
introduction to calculus course with the
Wolfram language so John is did calculus
in the seventh grade on his own passed
the AP calculus in ninth grade went to
Kara Tech and finished up his degree and
he told me that you know at kinetic they
tell us what to do not how to do it so
this is basically his work and we now
have a complete course lineup for
Wolfram you calculus which should get
recorded probably in December or January
soon with that so it's got everything
you'd expect from a standard calculus
course from the Wolfram language point
of view so as to show you a sample
lesson you're the first one so that's
first question what is calculus so it
begins with calculus ayan such Ange
what are four main problems tangent to a
curve Arian length velocity problem
optimization what's the priest free of
calculus well here you are
early development and then question is
if all that happened before Newton alive
minutes what did they do so real
controversies did Newton language we
discover the calculus and that's a
subtle question okay and we discuss it
over here in what sense are Newton
reliability discoveries of calculus
going on further what happened after
them how is calculus used today
why studied what's the course about
who's it for
there could be a little girl from middle
school or could be a professionals in
old no time at all
Oh anyone who loves to do calculus in
Russian language so this is a complete
course for calculus which should come up
hopefully sometime in the next year and
be available to everyone on the web okay
so to summarize we have been focusing on
very concrete things recently corals
calculator bruh and the next step is
gold asymptotic expansions series
solutions etc and of course we keep on
driving education so that is the summary
of my talk and I thank you very much for
listening
then you questionnaire take them now yes
you